good afternoon everyone and welcome to
another live interview from the European
Parliament here in Brussels European
gender equality week is an opportunity
to recognize the barriers that women and
girls face in almost every aspect of
their life but also it's a reminder of
how far we have come in achieving equal
rights and equal opportunities so this
week parliaments is holding a series of
deep air of debates and events to to
address gender inequality and you can
check them in their dedicated website
and by the Evelyn Wagner will give us
more information about it she's the vice
president of the parliament in church of
the organization of the European gender
equality week I'm Maria and yeah
nice to meet you nice to see you thank
you for for your time and before we get
underway with the interview I would like
our audience to send us their questions
and comments and I'll try to put as many
as possible to my guest in the next half
an hour or so
this is the third European Union quality
Wing what would the European Parliament
like to achieve with it what we want is
visibility of the topic of gender
mainstreaming so what is gender
mainstreaming it's simply to think
whatever you're doing in politics
whatever you're doing in daily life
what is the effect on women what is the
effect on men and we just think of that
and you just live another life that's it
and we just do that looking into the
Committees so what does it mean for
example gender means streaming when you
think about Mobility who is using the
public transport and who is going by car
what does that mean when you're talking
about who is getting financing of
a smart new company is it a demand is
the women why is more demand and all
this and when you just dig deeper you
just find a lot of solution and it's
really great what we learn so you have
just mentioned a gender mainstreaming
which is like including gender in
policies which are not focused directly
on it have there been any progress on on
gender mainstream of course otherwise I
would be desperate I mean just think of
the rrf the recovering resilience funds
I mean
750 billion Euro I mean that's a huge
sum and we
we would just emphasized and insisted
that gender equality is in mind that
means the member states who are right
now trying to invest all this money have
to ask I mean is this money only for men
is it also for women for which Pro for
which projects for example for child
care or what you need in order to make
the whole the whole economy resilient
and and this is really I mean if you
invested in a good way it's really a
match and besides that whether some of
the most important issues that
Parliament is struggling this weekend in
general yeah in general during this term
so on gender equality on gender
mainstream yeah I mean in European
Parliament I really would like to say uh
I mean of course we are confronted like
every other every other person I mean
with a backlash we have in many
countries at the national level and also
with kovit so somehow there is negative
impact but and I really would like to
talk about the good news there's a lot
of legislation ongoing dealing exactly
with improving the situation of both men
and women because gentleman's streaming
means to look at both sides so it's on
pay transparency we'll finish the women
on board so the quarter is coming we
talk about the carers the carer strategy
which is so important and of course
terrible topic we have to go for
violence against women so and all this
on legislation I think that's already
something you have just mentioned a
gender violence that's the European
Union need a special legislation to
combating gender-based violence and
intimate partner environments absolutely
we need absolutely legislating
legislation we need binding measures
first of all we need the implementation
of the Istanbul convention that is a
convention that simply says it is the
task a public task of the governments to
care about women to protect them not to
be hit for example not to experience
violence so that's the golden standard
we have to push that and we need
legislation and we got it right now and
we're negotiating on that cyber violence
I mean so many women are really exposed
and therefore made calm
they don't dare many of those Brave
women they don't dare to say a word
anymore as journalists or as as
courageous young women when you have a
[ __ ] storm that is uh even going wild
and crazy and violent so we have to to
do something about that it's a crime
violence against women is a systematic
special crime and that needs to be taken
on board on the list of Euro crimes
kind of mentioned it already but there
is a question from from Clay on
Instagram and he asked is there any
legislation currently being dropped
drafted to improve how illegal system
prosecute sexual assault
so what do you mean by by sexual assault
um I guess also somehow this is kind of
like to understand I mean um I guess
we have right now uh a proposal from the
commission on the table which is
important so we as parliamentarians
we're heavily asking for that I insisted
on I mean violence can be online can be
offline sexual harassment I mean this is
also crazy and when you're for example
uh confronted with I don't know porns or
uh when you are confronted with sexual
harassment it was all crime so here yes
we have the proposal from the commission
right now on the table and really goes
in on it and we just have to look at the
specific gender perspective because most
of the time something else being a woman
makes you more exposed
okay so when we think of gender
inequality perhaps one of the most
obvious
issues that stands out to people is the
gender pay Gap so what is the European
Union doing to tackle this gender Vega I
mean we have really too close that
because everything else is crazy we have
in our Au treaty already for I don't
know more than 70 years equal pay for
equal work and work of equal value so we
have to do something to close the the
pay gap between men and women we have
the legislation on the table we're in
the trailers and it is very important
that I mean that every every woman has
the rights and not only the right the
accessibility to the courts to fight for
the right that we have the uh the change
of the burden of proof so that it's not
the woman who has to prove that her
colleague her male colleague is earning
more and we of course have to help that
it's not coming to the worst case so
somehow the closing the pay Gap means
transparent figures that companies have
to do their job that the governments
have to go for this transparency that
you then take your Works Council support
and go to your company Chief and say hey
how I would like to compare my uh my
wages my salary and then when you just
see my colleague obviously having the
same qualifications earning more so then
please hurry on and catch up so we
really have this legislation on the
table right now hold the fees the
presidency the Czech president is very
constructive we really want to finish
this as soon as possible
yes in what other ways can gender
equality manifest and affect women and
gender diverse people as well
I mean we have to look at all sort of
inequalities that exist I mean being a
woman and somehow always being
confronted with lower pensions with
lower wages exposed to harassment
carrying more or less responsibility of
looking after
the children the elderly the ill one and
that's already the majority women but
many of these women are having also the
background of Migrant backgrounds or
somehow social issues are also important
so somehow when you're coming from a
poorer background it's always more
important to fight for your right than
those having a more
a more let me say better Financial
background of course you have all issues
like LGB IQ so somehow sometimes it's a
double burn and we have to go to this
intersectional components both in the
patrons parents directive and of course
everywhere everywhere beats who is the
chief more diversity should be should be
in and that's also part of gender
mainstreaming it was gender
mainstreaming looks on the gender but
looks also what what is the other
background so somehow there are more
reasons to be discriminated and after 10
years of delay the council has finally
adopted their the number of women on
boards yes right and so that you were
celebrating it on in your Twitter
account so what does this mean for
European women and and what are the next
tips yeah I mean this is really
important I mean it's overdue we have to
say that 10 years of negotiating and
pushing and again putting on the table
it looked like the council doesn't want
it but we managed it and I'm really glad
and I'm also proud for I mean there's
also a women's thing never give up be a
marathon runner simply don't give up and
go for the issues and I think this is so
important
for both women and men that we abolish
the male quarter it's the other way
around now you just have networks and
often non-objective criteria why men are
getting into these top positions and of
course it has an effect because you look
at the role models who is on the top so
it is it's good for for the whole
society we heard it from Italy when they
introduced the national court that they
said great the overall quality of
company boards is going up so it's a
win-win for everybody and it is
especially right now important because
we have so much backlashing many member
countries women are made more invisible
pushed a little bit out of of great
positions and of what we have achieved
and therefore it's important to say look
the European Union is doing something
legally binding you have to implement
that so somehow we really should
celebrate that and if I can ask where
there's so many different between member
states I mean you have different
approaches I mean you have those who say
women shouldn't be on the top looking
Hungary so somehow here on the board so
it was even going down so it's also it's
not only a rule of law it's also
concerning women's progress that is
reflected and then you have countries
that say we should do that with
voluntary measures women are so great
they do it because they are good but I
just tell you something if we're going
on with this speed we wait another
hundred years and we don't want to so
somehow again it's not on
introducing a female quarter it's just
abolishing the man's quarter via
introducing objective criteria so
somehow take a little bit a rucksack of
women they have to carry in order to to
make it to the top top and give a little
bit more balanced possibilities for both
and more than ever women are working are
doing like pain paid work but they still
do most of them unseen and unpaid care
work like including taking care of the
children of the or of the older member
of the family so how can I'm paid or
underpaid care work be tackled a lot of
work to do
I mean the closing the pay Gap is
already one instrument because also
especially young men want to better work
but life balance I learned it again and
again it's both men and women to work
yes but also to stay with family and
friends and to have a good life and when
the pay Gap is closed it's easy for a
couple to say okay let us better share
that's one uh one thing but of course
it's only one piece of the mosaic the
most important thing is changing the
mindsets it's changing the mindsets that
for example a man doesn't call uh his
woman when he says okay I do the
shopping the supermarket so I'm a brave
man I do my thing I go to the
supermarket then calling from the
supermarket please tell me what is
missing in the fridge woman sitting in
the in her job
has to scratch your head think a little
bit because she has a picture of the
full fridge or the empty fridge it says
okay I think I know we need some cheese
and so on so somehow it's changing the
culture doesn't mean sharing but it
means also sharing the responsibility
sharing the mental load sharing to feel
responsible of what has to be done when
caring about kids when thinking about
what is missing in the fridge what has
to be done and and this we can do for
example by sharing the same time the
parent leave because we know when at the
same time men and women stay in the same
period at home this changes habits so if
you only just stay with a little bit at
home for the kids when we're small you
just maybe learn to bring down the
Dustbin but not that you change
completely your daily life and after a
certain while this helps we have as
legislators the uh the the the job
to have to create a better
um
frame and this means equal earners equal
care strategy uh that there has to be
um
more child care facilities that are
really overall affordable and good
quality to give an example and the same
with elderly and with those opinion
so I'm going to do some of the questions
and comments of our followers and well
just to let you know there are many
hellos from everywhere like European
countries such as Spain Portugal Poland
Scotland but even from Afghanistan guys
so in the program of the European
General quality week that the recent
events on Afghanistan um can you maybe
sell this follower who is watching us
from there what he can expect I just say
I mean I'm so proud of all these great
women but also men supporting Afghan uh
women but also jumping over Iran and in
what we see there fantastic uh
resistance of strong women being
supported by their brothers sisters
friends so somehow I just can't tell
them for us
Afghanistan is really in in my heart and
and what is happening there because it's
so tough
I got to know so fantastic female
leaders being so strong and saying okay
we stayed there we we just don't give up
the resistance and therefore what is the
message to them is
gender mainstreaming means doing foreign
politics in the European Union is
you we always have to look at the
situation of women in the respective
countries and not only to look at them
to include them to include the women
leaders you can't go there and talk to
anybody being one of those terrible
rulers of the Taliban without taking the
same time at the same I hate those
female leaders on board and that's the
same thing concerning distribution of
goods and support in camps and wherever
people who are fleeing it always has to
be taken on board what's the situation
of women and again including them
because they're brilliantly intelligent
great Afghan female leaders this is also
our task is European Union wherever it
is also with Iran yeah I was gonna go to
Iran now because we also received many
questions about it and one of them has
seen me on Instagram is asking if
Parliament has plans to support Iranian
protest we do that already I mean mean
as far I mean when we just learned that
I mean the first thing was we we just
have to do a plenary debate in order to
show the full support of them and we
have to explore further what to be done
you've realized sanctions of the
European Union very quickly
towards Iran also somehow it seems sort
of a systematic thing those who are
attacking women and women who are
expressing their rights I mean it's just
normal things they they would like to do
Sports and the industries have fun
whatever
somehow use
also oppressive suppressive means on
concerning War so from my point of view
it's almost sort of an inner logic
somehow this support of Iran towards
Russia uh being aggressor and
attacking the Ukrainian people so
somehow
feminist politics in this sense means
that we are supporting women but we're
supporting also the men who are
supporting women we're supporting those
who are going on the streets and
fighting for a society with values with
values as we have in the European Union
so yes is the answer okay
then going to another question from one
of our followers Eddie King kamalov is
saying how to change perception of
public and gender violence within a
patriarchal society yeah it's difficult
I mean I just say that right now not as
a vice president but also as a member of
my party from the uh from the from the
Socialist we just start a campaign yeah
and I think this is something every
party and where whoever also with as
Parliament could use taking pictures I
mean showing a picture of a hand a man
in a glove just repairing a car
and then showing the same hand also with
a glass also a strong man's hand just
taking a brush and cleaning the toilet
so if you're that strong that you can
repair a car you are also strong enough
to clean the toilet and this is just one
example we have many other examples
simply to show it's about sharing I mean
and
sharing means we have to go for
campaigns I mean simply to make it
visible uh and they're a really great
campaigns existing and we have to go on
with that
but also of course also going into
legislation and I think that's what
we're doing right now also when we are
talking about stereotypes existing
stereotypes that are existing
um
supporting everybody doing rules on
sexual harassment I think I don't it's
not only a think I know I'm convinced
he's like that that me too and the way
we treat is a whole issue that sexual
harassment is part of all our daily
lives it's taking place in the film
industry is taking place in the
parliament it's taking place in the
sport world it's happening at
universities so somehow when you just
open this box and make
those visible
who are suffering and those supporting
them via measures via trainings
mandatory trainings for example here in
this house pushing very much everybody
should go for a training then you just
can improve the situation of course it's
never it's just one tool it's many tools
it's legislation it's changing culture
and it's going also uh
really been proud making visible all
those fantastic people who show what was
going wrong yesterday we had a
journalist a Belgium journalist who made
a documentary
about her personal case of being really
stalked and and violated via online in a
terrible way and she what was her
reaction she made a documentary on that
she made a film on that
giving the space and the room and the
visibility to those women who would like
to speak about that when you do that I
mean this is already a gorgeous a
gorgeous input in order to improve the
situation because everybody who sees
them afterwards says all these guys
they're so perverse so it's not an
exception it's a system
yes you already mentioned few samples
but for those who are watching us
welcome people in general do to help
achieve gender equality like people who
are watching us now
they can do everything I mean everybody
can do a lot whatever you're doing think
always
what does it mean for men what does it
mean for women simply ask this question
and again I give an example
uh
Sweden
um
in Sweden it's snowing a lot yeah I mean
in winter so
and it's a question of the of gender
mainstreaming I mean what does it mean
for men when those being responsible for
cleaning the streets from from the snow
ask this question because the plow who
is removing the snow has to decide do we
start with the road where the cars are
going or do we start with the sidewalk
why
generally in the morning when the the
polls do the job they just clean the
street first
and it's more men driving by car to the
work while I mean just not everybody but
in general it's like this while women
having the kid on their hand going to
the kindergarten and accompanying to
school before before also going to their
job so somehow of course when you ask
this question it means let us remove
first the straw the snow from the from
the sidewalk where the pedestrians are
going and then to go to the road and
this is just a simple everyday question
you can do that wherever you are when
you're just sitting in the in the tram
as a as a young guy and you're just
sitting like this you can just can ask
yourself I mean
does a woman feel comfortable with you
it's just simple and too man spreading I
mean simply ask daily questions
sometimes in your behavior that's it and
I think with this I mean nobody is
perfect because of course we're doing
all a lot of mistakes but with this we
can learn from each other because
Dynamic streaming means also learning
not only men learning from women it
means also women better understanding
classic man's behavior and then change
our our habits so thank you I think they
are very useful examples here which
everyone can apply I remember when I
first interviewed you it was online
because we were stuck at home yes so
indeed during the pandemic years
everyone's mental health was tested and
tried why is caring for mental health so
important during those challenging times
and especially from a gender perspective
I mean why
it is
a basis for democracy that people are
not getting crazy and and suffering
it is the basis of
health
that you also uh are in good shape
concerning mental health it's the basis
of
somehow feeling comfortable in your skin
so it's it's extremely important and I
think this is really an issue present
right now but will be present also very
very long I think that's one of the most
important health issues in the upcoming
decades
um
I I launched a project a a pilot project
for myself because not on Mental Health
on loneliness but loneliness and mental
health are very much interlinked because
who is lonely I was just looking just
with this experience
what did kovitz this a lot been alone or
somehow living a complete alone means
um without support from outside to
somehow in a difficult mental situation
what does it make especially with young
people and what does it make with women
I just asked that and launched this
project because violence against women
was going up mental health I mean it's
one thing is mental health I mean if and
the other thing is I mean just
everything else so somehow to be also
physically healthy
and when
mental health is not only a topic for
young and for women it's also for men
and issue and when the mental health of
man is getting crazy women are suffering
so mental health is a huge issue we we
have to tackle to tackle and we just I
would say in very much in the beginning
but what we need is far more data and
far more
psychological help at schools first of
all I really think in this regard not
only of women but also of those somehow
I would say having suffered the most
being young and and and having been
exposed the most to deal with it so
there can be a lot done but with just
still very much at the beginning we need
more medical stuff that's clear we
absolutely need more medical stuff so I
think this is really a a good job
idea for those thinking what they should
do professionally before you said that
in order to achieve gender equality we
had to change mindsets so would you say
that younger Generations are more
concerned
regarding gender equality and also how
is the social media promoting feminism
I mean social media doing a lot to the
good but they're also doing a lot to the
bad I mean I think many of us being in
social media and putting on feminist
content somehow just get like uh like
like a hit in the face I mean all these
crazy
comments from from trolls so it's really
also I really would like to to to say we
have to do something legally against
this danger of democracy this danger
also of Integrity of women's personal
rights against these attacks that are
existing so I mean there are good things
happening but unfortunately also very
bad ones yeah
so my last question would be what advice
would you be good you give to young
women who want to succeed as a leader
my dear
do networking
go for gangs
I mean really don't stay alone
for young for young women it is very
important to look where is my role model
but also where is my space my safe space
in order to exchange in order to help
each other to give the hands to build
the networks to make each other strong
and
don't forget the boys and don't forget
the man they're on they're not bad
to your last question of course young
men they also want work-life balance I
really hear that all the time they they
most of the younger people they're fed
up with the classic picture of the
society so for for really for young
women or my advice is really
um don't think it's done you have to
fight for that and it's really a tough
fight but
um
together I mean really in groups in
parties in whatever in in whatever is
beating sports or wherever have fun as
well uh you you really can change a lot
so miss regener thank you very very much
for your time I hope that this week is a
success
and for those who are watching us thank
you for tuning in once again have a good
afternoon and don't forget to to see the
events of the European gender equality
week in our dedicated website thank you
and have a good afternoon thank you so
much and thank you